breakups makeups a bit of Bollywood at
glamour and even a proposal it's all in
a normal week for the dirty Rascals but
will there be more fireworks in tonight
big series finale while we're joined by
two the show's cast away Scarn and
Shamal Siddiqui welcome to you both
thank you very much for coming I have to
turn to you first week I have I have
seen a few episodes I think it's fair to
say you are the bad boy of the series so
I've been told I would like to say that
I'm a bit misunderstood rather than the
bad boy but at least I've given people a
reason to watch it okay now the pull of
this show is that although it's looking
at it's in the vein of sort of TOWIE and
Made in Chelsea looking at the Asian
community in the various generations but
it doesn't just appeal to the Asian
community does it why do you think that
is I mean it's it gives an insight into
the culture and you know we're used to
believing the stereotypes which fuel our
community and it's good to see us in a
more positive light you know modern
modernization of us and you know we're
an integrated part of society I'm just a
close-knit community which people think
so so yeah no it's really good should we
take a look at a clip I think this
speech is the bad boy let's see never
had a boyfriend because she won't foster
to a best mate that she can yell hi
grace
that was distinctly lacking in laughs
their first time wired kind of like
second time I'd ever got by the stage
but I got the reaction I wanted it
together and that was filmed just this
week and that's being broadcast tonight
was a quick turnaround yes it's a very
fast turnaround it's kind of film three
days two threads prior to it and then
it's aired because it's kind of it it
makes all the audience interact with us
a little more and it's more kind of up
to day in this way there's less editing
time which makes it even more real
really and has it thrust you into the
spotlight have you become celebrities
been recognized on the streets not no
negative at all especially for me most
but great because a lot of it if you
don't mind me saying so is about you
looking for love the positive is that
everybody knows you're available now yes
I had some interesting offices the show
started actually yeah so hopefully I
will find the one she might even be
watching now the frame in TOWIE and
anyways Essex and a lot of the cast
complain about the editing sometimes
that it's not necessarily representative
what actually happened have you felt
that have you experienced that has it
been a good representation of what you
guys have been up it's been very
accurate you know the emotions come
across it does come across very accurate
the emotions are all very real and it is
very much you see exactly how we felt
the time has it's just very quickly to
run out of time has there been any
criticism from the Asian community that
this isn't realistic this isn't really
true I'm not really no I think all the
Asian community have supported us really
well so they can relay
so each individually I released it we
bring with each of us bring something
different to the show and people within
the communicator can relate to it wasted
tomorrow thank you very much thank you
charlie reeling from that almost
marriage proposal let's take us into
this whole flattered at my age